the problem is that i think we've
engineered a society and you know you've
talked about this with automation and so
on where it's getting easier and easier
and easier to have
more layers of psychological distance
between people who are
affecting your life and you
and the evidence is very very clear that
the more psychological distance between
one person and another the easier it is
to abuse them to view them as disposable
to start to treat them you know like
they're insignificant
and you know you think about the
corporate downsizing consultant the
person who sort of got the job of just
coming in to fire you because nobody in
the corporate you know corner office
actually wants to deal with that
and you know i think i think we've
created a world that is built for
psychological distance uh even things
like drone strikes
you know i mean drone strikes create
psychological distance more than dude
social media like people behave on
social media in a way they never would
in real life you know yeah i mean i
always i always think about that when i
get like these hateful comments on my on
my twitter i'm like nobody has ever said
something like this to me in person and
you get this like
that's why you know that's why i'm
really pleasant on social media that i'm
a total dick in real life like it gets
you in person i'm gonna be like i'm
going to tell you things you have never
heard before
to your face
and then on social media i'm like you
know
like keep going
i mean i'm kidding but uh but but when
you talk about the psychological
distance this is actually one of like
the grave dangers of our there's so many
great dangers of our time and we're
we're pretty [ __ ] but the um
but that there's this erosion of
sympathy and empathy um and and then
there are these i'm going to say like
kind of performative displays of
sympathy and empathy that i don't think
i'm out to the real thing
it's like you know
like you're if if you have a choice
between helping someone in real life or
like proclaiming on social media how
much you give a [ __ ] like tell the world
how much i care as opposed to you know
how you actually tell someone you care
it's like go out and like do something
about it and no one will ever know you
did anything about it that'd be a more
genuine expression
[Music]
this week on forward political science
professor and author of the new book
corruptable who gets power and how it
changes us brian class talks about how
we can actually build a system that
brings in the people we want and gets
rid of the corruption that unfortunately
is becoming widespread brian class this
week on forward
hello and welcome to the forward podcast
someone who wrote an entire book on a
subject that's near and dear to my heart
that book is
corruptable who gets power and how it
changes us
political scientist host of the aptly
named power corrupts podcast brian class
brian welcome
thanks for having me it's great to be
here so brian
uh
how long have you been super powerful
and how long did it take you to have
your soul corrupted and become very very
dark
well
i don't think that i'm super powerful
myself i mean i have a bit more of a a
bit more of a platform than i once did
uh which i still find very weird i mean
i i find it very weird to be speaking to
you to be honest because you're an ultra
famous and accomplished person but uh
but i think this is one of those one of
those things where i've been studying
really powerful people for the better
part of a decade and and what i started
doing was um you know i sat down with
various former desk bots and and war
criminals and so on in my early research
and uh i started to wonder the
germination of this book was i started
to wonder you know
what is this like at the more like
normal level what are these dynamics of
these kinds of people also experiencing
the same things in their head when
they're you know in in charge of a local
homeowners association or running for
president or doing things a bit more
close to home so the book is trying to
sort of understand power in all of its
nuance and complexity and how it changes
people and affects them and who seeks it
and all of that well you you clearly
have a very deep interest in the subject
because not only did you write a book
but your podcast is literally named
up to this so um so tell us a little bit
about how you came to this it seems you
studied political science so is that
when this interest kicked in and then
how do you make a career out of this
because i'm sure people would love to
hear about that yeah sure so i mean i
when i explain what i do to people uh
what i do in terms of like what my
professional life is like i say i study
bad people who do bad things and that's
typically you know the sort of through
line in a lot of my research so i
started traveling around the world and
and studying these people talking to
them having breakfast with them uh
sometimes you know
drinking a beer with them whatever it
was
and what was really fascinating to me is
that there's there's this sort of weird
thing that happens to you when you sit
down with someone who's you know a
corrupt kingpin in madagascar and you
start to sort of like them you know i
think there's something are they
charming yeah they're they're charming
they're funny they have complexity and
nuances to them
and you sort of you know what i started
to to think about was
how can i convey there's this disconnect
between like my moral judgments of some
of these people and then also like my
understanding of why they exist the way
they do because i think i think one of
the things that we often do in politics
is we just sort of say
what's wrong with the leaders we have
and we're not thinking about some of the
other components of this throw the bombs
out brian throw the bums out
well you and i agree on that i mean you
and i agree that there's a lot of
problems with uh
with the current crop of leaders but but
i would say no no i'm going to follow up
with this brian is that like i'm joking
about it because i am profoundly in
agreement with what ezra klein wrote
which is that
corrupt systems compromise good
individuals with ease uh and we keep
having this fantasy that like oh if only
i could get that one moral person in
there then everything will be well and
there are various
both candidates and uh political
movements and media organizations that
reinforce that myth that i believe is a
myth it's like hey guess what you could
get a relatively moral person into
a corruptive system and the system's
gonna win like like that person's not
gonna show up and all of a sudden the
pipes are going to become squeaky clean
yeah you know i so i started with this
question of like does power corrupt or
or do corruptable people seek power and
i think the answer is definitely both
and i think you're completely right
about this because we often have these
little quips i mean the power corrupts
absolute power corrupts absolutely line
has been said to me hundreds of times in
my career and what i always say back is
yeah that's just the very very
scratching the surface of this story
it's a much more complicated picture
because we ignore the systems there's
there's a perfect study i think that
that really captures this where they
these economists took uh students and
they had them roll a dice 42 times and
then they said every time you get a six
we're going to give you some money but
you get to report how many sixes you
have rolled so you can lie
now using statistical methods i could
figure out who was lying and who was
telling the truth and when they did this
study in india where the system is
pretty unclean in terms of bribery and
and sort of kickbacks and so on the
students who lied disproportionately
wanted to go into the civil service they
wanted to extract the bribes
when they did the exact same study in
denmark where the the bureaucracy is
notoriously clean it was inverted all of
the students who told the truth were the
ones who wanted to go into civil service
and public service
what was it in the states bro what was
it in the states they didn't do it in
the states i know but but i think i
think we know the answer of what that
would be right i mean i think i don't
think it takes a huge logical leap to
imagine
uh that this would be a very bad finding
in the us and i i think what i was
trying to do in the book was to say okay
look we accept that power corrupts
people it turns them worse we accept
that worse people are disproportionately
drawn to power for the wrong reasons
what are we going to do about it you
know i think the answer is you have to
engineer systems to counteract these
tendencies that seem to be
relatively immutable that we have
design systems by accident that attract
and promote all of the wrong kinds of
people to the highest echelons of our
society and i think that's a massive
mistake where we haven't debated how we
actually change the system itself
i love it that's why i enjoyed both your
thinking and your book immensely and one
thing that your book did in spades
is provide solutions or suggestions for
solutions you're like how can you
actually solve this problem and
listeners to this podcast know that one
pet peeve of mine is that we don't do
that
where you you'll read a book and they'll
scare the [ __ ] out of you with a very
thorny problem you'll be 90 in and then
you'll be like how do we fix it how do
we fix it and then the solutions are
generally so tepid
and half-assed and uh you know like kind
of throw your hands up in hand wavy that
i
i
very often just you know like literally
throw the book down in disgust uh do i
do that in real life you know
in my head yes i do i'm not really a
book thrower but um in your case your
book actually dug into the solutions
with very very real
concrete suggestions so first let's set
up the problem a little bit more and
then we'll go into your solutions which
i enjoyed a great deal and agreed with
just about all of them um so first let's
set the stage about the corruptive
nature of power which most people kind
of accept
uh if you've read my stuff listener if
you haven't you should go out and buy it
now but if you
if you
pay attention to my stuff like i had i
wrote an excerpt that uh it sounds like
you saw on politico
about how running for office tends to
screw you up now you're suggesting that
screwed up people run for office more
often which i i
will say is consistent with my
experience
you will see people who do run for
office for the right reason and they're
very very striking because you're like
wow this person is actually genuine and
you're like oh i really want to help
this person like that that person does
exist
um i'm going to say that person is
actually like a significant proportion
of the candidates that i've met and
supported
um but
you know like of the myriad people who
run for office are a lot of them
folks who just want a little slice of
power or like a like a you know better
role or a better gig or have to boss
people around and the rest of it
sure
[Laughter]
is that what the data shows as well
yeah you know i think i think this is
something where we have quite a lot of
evidence to suggest that the wrong kinds
of people are are drawn to power
and and i think when we think about why
that is it's not actually that difficult
to understand i mean it's you think
about like a high school basketball team
tryout right there's going to be not a
representative sample of people at that
tryout there's going to be taller kids
than usual uh you know going out for the
team the same is true for power p people
who are power hungry or who
view power as an obsession for which i
mean sometimes psychopaths machiavellian
uh individuals narcissistic individuals
you know for them it's like moss to a
flame they're really really attracted to
it and also they're really good at
getting it i mean this is one of the
dangerous aspects of it is that we've
set up systems and some of this is
unavoidable potentially in politics but
also in business is that you know you
have a very superficial assessment of
someone so like the job interview it's a
45 minute format where you're trying to
make people like you i mean if you're a
psychopathic chameleon-like
machiavellian narcissist it's the
perfect stage for you to sort of show up
impress people and and get the job and
of course the same is true for
promotions and so on and one thing i
imagine i mean i'd be interested to hear
what you say about this but one of the
really strange things about electoral
politics is there's loads of people who
have opinions about you
but they don't know you right and you
have to sort of win them over in these
little snapshots of a 30-second
conversation or a 10-minute debate
answer well 10-minute debate you know
one-minute debate answer but continue
yeah exactly
exactly but you know my my point is that
you have these little snapshots when
we're and we're supposed to assess like
is this a good person is this a bad
person are they honest are they
trustworthy but then the thing that
really resonated about that that excerpt
from your book that i think is so so
refreshing to actually see somebody
write about this from the first person
is that you know your experiences were
strange most people don't walk into
these rooms full of cheering people on a
daily basis but also it's not just
psychological it actually changes your
brain chemistry i mean this is one of
the things i found really interesting
in researching the book and i was trying
to get you know evidence from wherever i
could get it so one of the guys i talked
to
is somebody who studies monkeys and he
has like a dea class 2 license and he's
got you know peer cut cocaine and a safe
in his in his office basically and uh he
takes these monkeys and they're all
individually housed so they're not in
any sort of social hierarchy then he
puts them in groups of four and like
immediately it goes one two three four
you can tell who the top monkey is who
the bottom monkey is and so on
and then they put them in a chair and
they can either pull a lever to get some
banana pellets or they can pull a lever
and get intravenous cocaine into their
bloodstream and all the dominant monkeys
take the pellets and all of the
subordinate monkeys take the cocaine and
then when they open up the brains later
on and they scan them the dopamine
receptors have changed and you know it's
actually fundamentally shifted their
brain chemistry so i think you know the
story of power corrupts is this little
you know it's like this thing you tried
to
powerful confident monkey chooses the
banana pellets over the cocaine
what'd you say like why does the
powerful alpha monkey
opt for the banana pellets uh over the
cocaine
yeah so the idea here is that there's
not there's not a sort of stress
response from being in a position of
authority you sort of are getting many
of your needs met they're more children
they're like oh okay like i you know
just
hit i'm pretty
straight just give me some banana
pellets whereas the
the junior subordinate monkeys are so
stressed out they're like i need drugs
is that right
that's that's exactly right but the the
good news uh the good news though for
people who are obsessed with power and
may not have have obtained it uh is that
actually being at the top of the
hierarchy can be bad for you too so i
mean this is another area where i looked
at both evidence from non-human primates
and also from you know human society and
when they look at baboons they can study
uh with this process called dna
methylation how fast the actual baboon
is aging on a genetic basis like a
biological basis as opposed to you know
on a calendar basis and what they found
is at the very bottom of the hierarchy
the baboon aged very quickly it was
stressed it didn't have resources it
didn't have mates as you went up the
hierarchy it got better until you hit
the alpha position and then it was
extremely stressful and that that baboon
actually aged by far the fastest or much
much faster than it would have had it
been near the top but not actually at
the apex and we've we've seen this with
uh presidents as well there's a study of
two oh everyone knows about the aging of
the presidents but continue what is the
data set
it's worse than it's worse than even the
appearances of the gray hair because
they're over 200 years in 17 countries
they tracked the winner of an election
versus a candidate who lost the election
and the average
president who won and this is across 17
countries died 4.4 years sooner than the
people who lost so uh you you may have
not
won the presidency andrew but you might
live for four and a half years longer
than some of these other people so
that's always good yes i won anyway
that's right brian that's what a power
mad person would say
[Music]
all right y'all it's 2022 and it's time
to get serious about your data and
internet privacy and security and that's
why we use expressvpn because odds are
if you're not using expressvpn
it's like going to the bathroom and just
leaving the door open it's like doing
something private but letting the world
freaking see it and that's why we use
expressvpn because it it's closing the
freaking door when you should be closing
the freaking door so these internet
service providers that you use all the
time they know every single website you
visit and they can sell this info to ad
companies and tech giants and use your
data to target you over and over and
over but express bpm puts a stop to this
it creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that your online activity can't be seen
by anyone it's great i use expressvpn on
all my devices i use it on my iphone i
use it on my mac you can use it on
routers it's awesome and the best part
about it is like plug and play just
download the app bang you're in express
bpn super simple it's the number one
rated vpn by mashable the verge and a
bunch of other outlets so
here's what i want you to do if you're
like me
you think people should go to the
bathroom in private
uh and believe your online activity is
your business secure yourself by
visiting expressvpn.com
yang today use our exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com
yang and you can get an extra three
months free which is an awesome deal so
that's expressvpn.com
yang protect your data do it the right
way get express vpn
i i will suggest that there is a native
mistrust of people i you know what
happened with me when i i decided to run
for president i think a lot of people
were like who the [ __ ] is this guy and
then it was like hey is he crazy uh is
he
uh a narcissist is he the rest of it and
then after they started
eliminating some of these possibilities
they were like oh wait maybe this person
actually just wants to give me a
thousand bucks a month they're like is
genuine or the rest of it but we come to
the table with a ton of mistrust like
you have to somehow walk through
someone's doubts and skepticism because
we're kind of conditioned to think if
you are doing something like run for
office and you're probably an [ __ ]
or
you know like really into yourself
um so
it's very stressful to be at the top i
think most people will understand that
natively because you see the president's
age there's that proverb heavy lies the
crown
and one of the things you say in your
book is like maybe you want to be
second
maybe you'd like to be the person next
to the
the leader
yeah you know i i think that's i think
that's right i think it's the idea of
sort of being in the court but not being
the king
and and i think that distrust is
understandable but i also think it's
something where you know we can fix it i
i have this sort of strange paradox in
the sense that i've i've met some of the
worst people on the planet i mean i've
i've met war criminals and despots and
torturers and all this and yet i
genuinely i genuinely believe that
people are on balance good and so i'm
i'm optimistic that if we tweak the
system in the right way uh
we can actually fix it i i wanted to
give an example of this and how what you
were talking about and sort of how the
system affects the the outcome so much
is with policing which is one of these
massive i mean it's a massive debate you
you had it in the new york city mayor's
race and so on
and uh
what i started to do is i started to
scour the internet to look at police
departments and sort of how they recruit
people and i found this video from
doraville georgia this little town of
like 10 000 people outside of atlanta
and the video is like it's absurd it's
it's it flashes the punisher logo this
guy who like you know tortures criminals
is like a vigilante and so on and uh and
then like these guys in a tank scream
into view and camouflage and they they
throw smoke grenades out the tank and
then the punisher logo comes back and
there's death metal music on it and i'm
like if you just want to be like a
community service cop like you're never
going to apply for that job right so i
then talked to the head of recruitment
for new zealand's police department and
they said we know about this which is
why we spent a lot of money designing a
different recruitment strategy and they
they set up this video it's gone viral
in new zealand it's very funny and
basically it depicts policing completely
differently it starts with you know it's
got a lot of ethnic minority cops who
are underrepresented in the force a lot
of women and so on they're chasing this
unseen perpetrator they stop to sort of
dance in the street with an old man
who's crossing the road and then they
get to the uh they get to the end and
they've caught the perpetrator and it's
a border collie who's stolen a woman's
purse
and instead of the punisher logo it says
do you care enough to be a cop on the on
the screen right
and and it's like
what what do you think happened well the
number of applicants shot up the types
of applicants were way more diverse than
they were before the relationship
between the police and the public
improved the levels of abuse declined
and it's like you know the way you
portray this really matters so when it
comes to things like distrust in
politicians i mean part of that is
because the current crop of politicians
has earned distrust
and so you know i think it's it's a
chicken or the egg problem to get better
politicians we need politics to look
like a virtuous
world
and
at the same time you know we we can't
have it be a virtuous world unless we
get better people into politics
oh yeah it's tough uh so
there's this aging factor that you
describe one of the the things that uh
i'm sure you also saw was around the
death of sympathy uh in the powerful
where your ability to empathize and
reciprocate emotion goes down and that's
an adaptive response because uh if
you're powerful you don't need to waste
your time mirroring someone else's
emotions
like it's an efficiency thing to be like
look i don't care what's going on with
you i'm just going to tell you what to
do
yeah you know this is there's a chapter
in the book called the weight of
responsibility that that this it's just
haunted me it's been lingering in my
thoughts for for so long because what i
did in the chapters i i juxtaposed this
guy ken feinberg who was in charge of
the 911 victims compensation fund where
he had to actually assign a dollar value
to the people who died on 9 11. i mean
it's a horrible horrible job
and he told me look every single day
what i did is i went to the office i met
with the families i heard their stories
and it was excruciating it was awful but
if it wasn't awful then i need to get
out of this line of work because i don't
understand the empathic aspect of this
so he forced himself to go through that
now another person i interviewed who i
juxtaposed with feinberg is john yu who
was the guy who wrote the depending on
your politics torture memos or enhanced
interrogation memos
and i asked him i said you know
i understand like your point of view on
this but
did you lose sleep over it like did this
bother you and he was just like
no it was a legal question like and i'm
like yeah but but like people were
waterboarded because of your legal
determination like does that ever occur
to you as like something you should
think about more he's like
no i just sort of moved on like it was a
legal question and that was it
and i thought to myself you know there's
there's what you're talking about which
is how people in power just sort of
end up losing that empathic response
over time but there's also this choice
that people can make to decide to
actually confront themselves with the
consequences of their actions and i
think that's something that we have to
insist on more that like you can't have
people be an abstraction to you and it's
one of the reasons why you know
when i saw you on the campaign trail and
so on this is something that's part of
politics you have to talk to people
and the more that you do that the more
that you understand like this isn't some
game this is actually people
having their life chances determined and
i think the more that people
are confronted by that the more they're
going to be a little bit more empathetic
than they would have been uh if they're
just sort of in the in the in the palace
so to speak uh looking down on the
little people yeah it's one reason why i
think we ask our political figures to
show up to
disasters and meet with people because
it's like look we need to know that you
feel that you understand
and there there are times when you know
i frankly i've been i've been parts of
lots of these occasions and there are
times when you're like okay
um like i feel like i'm just playing a
role and then there are other times when
you're like oh i'm really glad i'm here
because i'm understanding this problem
much better and i'm understanding the
suffering um i i can say from experience
like i've had both of those feelings um
but that there there's certainly
something very important about not just
starting to reduce everything to
uh i guess in john use case it was like
a legal determination because there
there's someone at the other end
yeah you know i'm i'm curious do you
mind if i ask you a question about this
because i think that i'd be
yeah so i mean
what i find really interesting about
this is when i've talked to you know as
i said i interviewed about 500 people
for for this research where do i rate in
terms of brain damage no i'm kidding go
ahead
believe me believe me you are you are uh
very different from a lot of these
people i talked to uh
it was some pretty uh pretty nefarious
figures that were on the interview list
so to speak but what i wanted to ask is
you know the thing that struck me about
some of these people who didn't turn bad
or turned you know managed to stay
themselves so to speak is they had
checks around them they had somebody who
actually they like had either delegated
to or had told point blank like if i'm
doing something keep me from being an
[ __ ] go ahead smack me around
like tell me like did you did you have
to sort of confront that where you're
like
it's it's time to have somebody you know
maybe it's a family member an advisor
who's just like this isn't the andrew
yang i used to know did i mean did that
ever come up in a conversation
well i joke all the time brian that uh
you know i
can take direction because i'm married
you know what i mean like if i came home
are you married i don't know this about
you
yeah well then you know what i'm talking
about but if i came home and was like
a consistent [ __ ] i think evelyn
would have like a
you know very very short
leash for that
should be like what the hell is wrong
with you
um so
i you know there is that in the world um
i didn't have
a
staffer i had assigned that role or was
like hey fyi if you know you see me
becoming callous and
um a jerk like please you know have me
spend some time with some some folks
that will remind me of my own humanity
like i didn't have that
but i will say that without someone like
evelyn in my life i probably could have
used someone like that i think that
they're so i you know i know people
and some of them have
uh families in their lives and then some
don't
and i think it's very very tough on
people who are doing certain kinds of
work like public facing work as an
example and then if you are on all day
and projecting and emoting and then you
come home and there's nobody
you know there's nobody for you to be
off around there's nobody for you
just to
you know put on the sweatpants or
whatever
i think that would derange one over time
and one point i'm going to make here is
that so it what's interesting is i i
think a lot of politics is [ __ ] like
a lot of it is theater and nonsense the
rest of it but there is this desire for
a political figure to have a family it's
like hey if this person can come home to
a family and
uh
you know be a good
partner and parent uh and the rest of it
then they must not be all bad
and i will say that
there's something to that
yeah no i i completely get that i mean i
think that's something where it's it's
it's a really strange but also
understandable aspect of our politics
because you're trying to use these
shortcuts to try to figure out what kind
of what kind of human being you are you
know what i mean it's like
you've got to make a decision as i say
and you don't have
any real interaction with the people
with the person on the ballot so you use
these little shortcuts that are are
supposed to be proxies for us and
sometimes they work and sometimes they
don't
yeah so in my case it is avalon that you
know keeps me human and i'm grateful for
it every day because
i do remember a time before evelyn and
it was tough you know you come home and
be like girl
why world
why are you so lonely
uh so yeah thank you evelyn thank you
for putting up with me and all of
uh our adventures the last several years
[Music]
so the the solutions you suggest
um i think that they they start with
something around this new zealand cop
story you spoke it of which is
try to actively recruit
the right people and screen out the
wrong ones
very very reasonable
yeah you know it's one of the things
about so i've got these 10 different
principles and and none of them are
really rocket science there's no like
political science wizardry that you're
going to come up with that will like
solve all these problems i think the
problem is no one's talking about how we
fix this
uh the the recruitment thing i think is
a very obvious aspect of it but it's
it's important it's that if you wait for
a self-selection of people into power if
you wait for those who are power hungry
to throw their hat in the ring i mean is
it really a surprise that that's who you
get as leaders and candidates and so on
and so i think you have to actively seek
out people for whom power is actually a
burden
i love it find some unwilling person
being like sorry we really need you to
do this you're gonna hate it it's gonna
suck please do it for all of our sakes
well there's that there's that there's
this line from douglas adams the uh the
author he says like anybody who can be
made president
anybody who can become president has
automatically disqualified themselves
from holding the job and i think there's
a grain of truth to that sometimes yeah
i agree
but i think you know the the the other
aspect one of the ones that i think is
uh is worth considering it's a it's one
of my more outside the box ideas but
it'd be reasonably easy to actually
implement if there was political will
is this idea of creating like a shadow
board in business and a shadow house of
representatives and politics and so on
based on randomly selected individuals
so you know in in ancient athens they
had this thing called the claritarion
which like it was basically like a jury
duty system it randomly assigned people
to the citizen assembly
and then they had to make decisions
about athens now i don't think that's a
very good idea in in general because i
think that politicians actually develop
some level of expertise on certain
aspects so we probably don't want to
just have a random assortment of people
making all the calls but i do think that
for oversight and accountability it
would be really good so if you had a
randomly selected 435 americans for the
house of representatives as a shadow
house and then you said look you get all
the same testimony same documents same
exact same expert experts etc and now
you have to decide the same things the
house is deciding
and you're going to do it publicly
you're going to make the sort of
statements publicly i think there'd be
some divergence on these things
i think you know and i think it would be
pretty obvious and i think that would
provide this really important level of
accountability and oversight to
politicians where you'd say like look we
put 435 like normal americans together
and they they came up with an
infrastructure bill in like an hour
why is it taking us you know five years
why is the why is it skewed where these
districts get so much more money based
on the relative power you know all of
that stuff would be exposed in quite a
clear way because i think you would have
reasonable discussion in in that in that
format and you could have the same in
business by the way i mean you know how
many boards that oversee businesses
actually understand what it's like to be
an employee in that company so you could
have a shadow board that's randomly
selected employees that are making
similar determinations as the board and
they're not binding but they actually
would have to be publicly released brian
class
pro shadow government that sounds very
very sinister brian
i don't know
i think
you've been corrupted my friend so um so
there are a couple of things i want to
say here first i completely agree that
the process of running for office weeds
out people that you would actually want
in charge and a couple of things i'm
going to suggest in this direction
uh introverts
introverts probably should be in charge
of more things but introverts
would cringe at the idea of putting
themselves out there every day and
schmoozing it up and glad hanging and
asking for money and everything else i
will say that i started out as an
introvert i was a very nerdy kid i won
most pensive
when i was five years old which means i
didn't talk and now you'd have to call
me an ambivert where i still think i'm
naturally introverted but i i obviously
now can
uh
perform or turn it on in a particular
way so we need more introverts in charge
and
we would need more people who as you say
are unwilling or you know not as excited
about the office and
people who have different types of
experiences which brings me to what
you're suggesting around this 435
average americans those 435 average
americans would look so different from
the house of representatives it is
insane because members of congress what
percentage are millionaires nowadays
like i think it's over 50
um the average age is 59 in congress i
think it's 64 in the senate
um i'm pretty sure it's
got to be like you know 70 dudes
like it's
it's uh certainly going to be much
whiter than the population
older whiter richer more male uh for
sure and so if you had 435
uh average americans they'd be
like the average age in america is 38 so
they'd be 20 years younger
like that would just be a start
they'd be you know from a completely
different generation
yeah i mean it's it's it's completely
true and i think that's important
because i think it's it's it's really
valuable to have
people in power who look like the the
people they're governing i mean there's
there's one study of it or at least live
like just two because they just don't
have lots of money but continue well
complete completely i mean completely to
understand what it's like
there was one study in india where they
randomly assigned village leaders and
uh
some were women and some were men and
the next generation
the number of women in who had tried to
become political leaders in the villages
that had a female leader for the first
time massively increased i think there's
something to that idea of seeing people
who look like you in positions of power
i was inspired to run by the previous
asian president
uh who i looked up and said
he could do it i could do it too
you you joke about that but i mean quite
honestly i think that's going to be an
effect that people will in you know in
five years on a podcast say i saw andrew
yang you know the good old andrew yang
effect
yeah but the but the introvert the
introvert point i think is a really
important one that's underappreciated
and it's it's i i started to study i was
you know i did some very strange things
in researching this book and one of them
was i i um sipped wine with the daughter
of a cannibalistic dictator uh
and
i was trying to figure out you know how
much of this is inherited how much of
the power thirst
is uh is inherited which isn't a crazy
idea because how much of it is inherited
well it's this this is the great
question so uh basically
we think there is a significant portion
that is the thirst of power there's
genetic studies that have looked into
this right and we know that in hyenas
dominance is inherited in zebrafish in
mice you can adjust genes and make a
mouse either super dominant or super
submissive and so on so there's
something to it in the animal kingdom
when they did a study trying to find a
power gene in humans they found one
and it was correlated to a pretty
significant degree with people ending up
in positions of leadership but this is
where the the study i think falters is
they can't say whether that gene caused
you to desire power or just made you
better at getting power so it may just
be the gene that's good for like being
affable and funny and charming and
extroverted and that's what's correlated
you know we don't really know so they
did twin studies they tried to you know
compare
fraternal twins with identical twins and
all that stuff you know i talked to the
daughter of a cannibalistic dictator she
seems to have inherited the thirst for
power a bit uh she actually gave me that
answer uh where she said uh
the backstory is this guy took power in
the 1970s in the central african
republic and
genuinely uh
he he fed dissidents to crocodiles and
served human flesh to one dignitary
allegedly so
not a good guy
and and his daughter when i asked her
you know do you have any desire to like
change your name or are you thinking
about running for office you know do you
want to not be associated with this guy
or do you want to sort of follow in his
footsteps
she said you know i'm really proud of my
last name and uh i'm not ruling anything
out when it comes to politics which is
like the classic answer when you're like
definitely going to go for it so uh yeah
i was i was a little worried about that
but but i think i think the end
answer is yeah and then she closed the
interview by saying you look delicious
well i did yeah i mean
i did i did uh remark on the fact that
she runs a tea room uh outside of paris
currently and i was like
i hope she's serving like you know not
serving people with tea
but instead serving people tea so
you know it's uh
but yeah that was a weird that was a
weird one
[Music]
so you've already touched on several of
the remedies you suggest for how we get
better people into positions of power so
so number one is try and recruit the
right people and screen out the not so
good ones number two
um is this shadow government you speak
of which i'm i'm going to say i make a
very very similar suggestion
that was from a guy named lawrence
lessig who you probably read his stuff
because he you know he's one of the big
thinkers in this space
um he he termed it civic juries which is
you get a bunch of people that
resemble a random cross section of the
country and then you ask them what they
would do
yeah
which i think is a good idea
i i agree now i love lesson number three
so much and i'm actually going to
suggest too that even number one which
is try and recruit good people
one way to do that would be to
have public campaign financing
because one of the things that scares
people off from running is no one wants
to be like hey i'm now going to have to
raise millions of dollars maybe i can't
raise millions of dollars maybe i don't
want to bug everyone i know for 50 bucks
like there's something really jacked up
about that process
um
and so if you have public campaign
financing i think that you end up
getting better people i i couldn't agree
with that more because i think you know
the way i explain this to people when i
sort of think about how what i found in
my own research is
okay let's imagine you've got sort of
two people one person one person wants
to run for office or become powerful for
the sake of power they're power hungry
the other person just sort of wants to
like serve their community or make the
world a little bit better they're both
gonna weigh it up right but the person
who's power hungry is gonna have so much
uh so much desire to obtain power that
they'll say oh you know if that means i
have to raise some money or face some
death threats or you know have my past
sort of raked over
so be it you know i care about power
enough it's worth it so i'm going to get
through to the next stage i'm going to
run the other person's just going to say
it's not worth it you know there's
there's actual costs
especially in the u.s political system i
think about you know school board
members these days who are getting death
threats for trying to implement public
health guidance you know
the reason i got interested in politics
myself was my mom ran for the local
school board and you know her biggest
issue at the time was like a pay dispute
now it's like you know my kids are going
to get harassed i might get death
threats i might have crazy people show
up in my house and all just because i
want to help the school you know it's a
rational thing to be like hey is this
worth it it's tough
and you're you're seeing it too
there's a story about how various
members of congress uh
backed down from impeaching trump
because they were getting death threats
and it's like well let me think like is
this really worth threatening my parents
my my family safety and having to go
into hiding uh maybe i don't know how
i'm gonna vote on this well and and i
think that's i think that's one of the
things where again you know it's like
it's why these reform conversations are
so important because like one of the
places that i do a lot of field research
in is bangkok in thailand
and
it's a place where going into politics
is genuinely extremely dangerous right
if you get on the wrong side of the
generals you could end up you get exiled
potentially killed you're going to lose
all your money almost certainly
and so when i talk to like you know
young up and coming smart
you know university graduates who are
just sort of starting on their careers
in bangkok it's like do you want to run
for office they're like why would i do
that that's like that's where you lose
it all so they all end up in business
you know and and what are you left with
and i think that's the point that like
we need to be really careful about that
like we have to make running for office
or climbing up the hierarchy in in
positions of leadership attractive
not just to the power hungry people
where they don't have to make a
cost-benefit reward you know analysis
and think
am i going to have to raise 12 million
dollars to run for the senate well you
know that doesn't sound fun i mean i
think that is it's a very astute point
because it's part of this broader point
that
when you have systems that are
unattractive to normal people you're
going to disproportionately attract the
people who are drawn to power for the
sake of power which is what i think has
happened in the united states
oh i'm sure a lot of people agree with
you ryan but i will say with each of
these principles came up i was like ooh
like there's an associated policy
so campaign finance would help civic
juries would help and number three you
have rotate to reduce abuse and you know
what that said to me my friend
term limits let's get them in and get
them out
yeah so i think i think there's a a a
real benefit to changing the people who
are in power regularly yup and and i
think it's something where you know
there's a question that i often wish was
asked of politicians which is
what what are you trying to achieve in
other words what is the thing that if it
changed if you got it you would think my
work here is done it's time for me to go
home you be honest
i i just i think that's that's something
we never frame political discussions
around like we don't say you know what
where are you going for you if you're
going to go there for four years what
are you hoping to achieve in the four
years when when will you give up power
uh and rotation i mean we have a lot of
evidence that this actually works really
really well because it reduces collusion
uh
you have this you know obviously in
police forces and banks and so on what
they do is they say look if you're with
the same partner for like 20 years and
you're both crooked that's a very
dangerous situation because it means
that you're going to protect each other
you'll both sort of take bribes you'll
extort people and so on and you'll feel
comfortable doing it you got a training
day that dude you got to say to him hey
are you cool
are you cool brian
we have we have lots of evidence that
this actually works and i think the the
principle also extends to the idea of of
rotation and politics because you get
these sort of these chummy clubs right
where they all think when that member of
congress shows up they sit them down
they're like so are you cool are you
going to be cool
[Laughter]
just a different uniform it's a suit
instead of the the badge and the uniform
i guess yeah oh yeah that something like
that's definitely going on there's some
very very weird corporate orientation
going on in
in congress
um on multiple levels
so um so this goes back to your don't
see people as abstractions um that
that's one of your big lessons here is
uh create reminders of responsibility um
just to let them know it's like hey
if you screw up they're gonna be some
real consequences you know very dramatic
story in your book about this where when
someone becomes prime minister in
britain the first thing you do is be
like what are you gonna do if there's a
nuclear strike and then you have to i
thought the story was fascinating where
you write instructions on a sealed
envelope where the person in the nuclear
submarine then opens it and to see what
you said to do
and the trick is that no one knows what
you said because everyone has to act
like you said
bomb whoever bombed us so that way no
one bombs us
but the real instructions could be
do nothing
and then the other another one was like
some like become
a part of the u.s
maybe it was another one which i found
really fascinating and then the other
choice was do what you want submarine
commander it is up to you
yeah you know the thing i love about
this so like i know this story because
it's now publicly available like we know
that this is what happens the first time
a prime minister the first day a prime
minister takes office is like the the
the first thing they're told is you have
to hand write these letters to the
submarine captains if london gets wiped
out by a nuclear blast
now what's interesting is up until like
the last i think decade and a half
nobody knew this existed except for the
people at the highest echelons of the
british government and what i was trying
to say is like imagine you've just
finished this campaign you've just won
you're now the prime minister and the
first thing that happens is somebody
tells you this and you have no idea it's
coming i mean the weight of
responsibility is going to hit you very
very quickly particularly during the
cold war i mean this would have scared
the hell out of people in the 1970s and
80s
and and i i think it's it's it's too
easy sometimes to lose sight
of how much power you actually have to
change other people's lives there's a
there's also a study that i cite in the
book that's
it's about this concept called
psychological distance and it's
basically saying like as humans we
triage who we care about you're going to
care about your family and then your
friends and then you know maybe your
co-workers depending on how good they
are and so on and and you have these
different layers that you sort of go out
and eventually you're going to stop
caring about people which is normal but
the problem is that i think we've
engineered a society and you know you've
talked about this with automation and so
on where it's getting easier and easier
and easier to have
more layers of psychological distance
between people who are affecting your
life and you
and the evidence is very very clear that
the more psychological distance between
one person and another the easier it is
to abuse them to view them as disposable
to start to treat them you know like
they're insignificant
and you know you think about the
corporate downsizing consultant the
person who sort of got the job of just
coming in to fire you because nobody in
the corporate you know corner office
actually wants to deal with that
and you know i think i think we've
created a world that is built for
psychological distance uh even things
like drone strikes you know i mean drone
strikes create psychological distance
more than dude social media like people
behave on social media in a way they
never would in real life you know yeah i
mean i always i always think about that
when i get like these hateful comments
on my on my twitter i'm like nobody has
ever said something like this to me in
person like you get this like
that's why you know that's why i'm
really pleasant on social media that i'm
a total dick in real life like it gets
you in person i'm gonna be like i'm
going to tell you things you have never
heard before
to your face
and then on social media i'm like you
know
like keep going
i mean i'm kidding but uh but but when
you talk about the psychological
distance this is actually one of like
the grave dangers or there's so many
great dangers of our time and we're
we're pretty [ __ ] but
the um
but that there's this erosion of
sympathy and empathy um and and then
there are these i'm going to say like
kind of performative displays of
sympathy and empathy that i don't think
i'm out to the real thing
it's like you know
like you're if if you have a choice
between helping someone in real life or
like proclaiming on social media how
much you give a [ __ ] like tell the world
how much i care as opposed to you know
you actually tell someone you care it's
like go out and like do something about
it and no one will ever know you did
anything about it that'd be a more
genuine expression
but now we we are replacing
uh action with expression
well and and i think it's also one of
those things that intersects with one of
those points we made earlier where
there's the performative aspect to it
and then there's also the aspect of how
easily you know systems or constraints
or cultures around us can make us worse
than we otherwise would be and we talked
about this with power already but
there's a there's a i think my favorite
study in the book because it's just sort
of like one of those ones that makes you
very depressed about how easy it is to
manipulate people's behavior is this
study where they have these um these
seminary students you know they're
they're training to become priests and
they're told to prepare a talk about the
good samaritan the parable from the
bible of you know helping the person
who's in need
and uh and then and then they're told to
go to the next building and to give the
sermon you know to pratt that they've
practiced what they don't know is that
the the researchers have put like a an
actor who's supposed to pretend to be
gravely injured between the two
buildings and that's some funny [ __ ]
yeah they created a good samaritan
moment on the way to give the good
samaritan lecture but you're late
well this yeah this is the beauty of it
so a third of the people get told like
you know take your time you've got
plenty of time a third of them are told
you're late you know it's fine but go
now and a third are like it's really
important you rush there and the people
who are told they're late
mostly stepped over the injured person
on the way to give the good samaritan
talk right it's like this tiny little
tweak in how you frame the problem made
priests who are giving a talk about the
good samaritan walk over another human
being in need and you're just like
wow i mean that speaks to the sort of
malleability of our behavior we can we
can change it depending on how we
structure society systems cultures tell
everyone to chill out
there's no rush
i guess
being late is always one of those
dangers but i i think the the broader
point is that you know
these this is why these conversations
about reform are so important because
there actually are tweaks that will make
a difference and and i think that's what
the the bottom line is here
[Music]
uh so another principle focus oversight
on the controller is not the controlled
i think most people would agree with
that
um and that's one of the concerns of
today is that we're trying to
uh focus a lot of attention on on um
folks who are
not exactly uh behind the steering wheel
in a lot of cases
we've we've ended you say that everybody
agrees on this but we've engineered a
society with exactly the opposite
principle right i mean it's like in in
pandemic workplaces where you're working
from home or whatever you there's new
technologies that actually some
companies have put like sensors in the
chairs to make sure that this person's
actually sitting there i mean it's so
dystopian and and yet it's not like
enron was brought down by you know the
person taking a five-minute extra long
lunch break it was it was the people who
weren't being watched who were
embezzling or cooking the books or
whatever
and so you know my point is that with
the responsibility of leadership comes
extra scrutiny and yet we have a lot of
the surveillance mechanisms of modern
society trained the people who can do
the least damage and i think it's very
bizarre that we've come up with that
system it makes sense because the people
who are setting up the system don't want
to be watched themselves but you know
the idea of like
keystroke logging for employees i mean
if you're going to roll that out for the
employees you better roll it out for the
ceo too i think and that's wow that ceo
would veto that [ __ ] and be like what
you're going to monitor my keystrokes
that's right through that brian
everyone's keystrokes now
are anonymized
i decree it um i just want to go on the
record and say if i were the incoming
prime minister of the uk and i was given
that choice i would uh write in the
envelope that the submarine commander
should do what they think is best
because i feel like they can process the
situation they can get new information
uh they can see what the most
appropriate action is i mean you've
given someone
control of a nuclear submarine like you
have to kind of assume that they
have a pretty good head on their
shoulders they're commanding you'd
assume also dozens of people
uh under seas for a length of time so
anyway just wanted to suggest that that
would be my move um
you know what i mean like i just seemed
like the best choice to me
um the there i'm going to tell a story
now about your next principle
um which is you say to utilize
randomness to
uh increase security with uh minimal
invasion of privacy and i'm just going
to tell a quick story i was a camp
counselor
at a camp for
um you know maybe like 12 year olds 13
year old something like that i was 19 or
20.
um and so the deal was that uh i was on
duty every other night
um but the campers didn't know which was
which
um
you know like i i was on duty for half
an hour after lights out
every night but then every other night i
could do whatever the hell i wanted
after that time um and so me and whoever
was off duty would go out and like go to
tgi fridays and get some drinks and the
rest of it
but i just remember what an effective
deterrent it was because to the kids it
was like i was always there like like
they didn't know i had every every other
night off
um so
like that like i i love the idea of like
like look you just need to insert some
randomness in there and just introduce
the possibility that someone could be
there and then all of a sudden people's
behavior will improve
yeah so so the i love that story because
it jives really well with the one that i
talk about in the book which is the um
the conversation i had with the former
head of internal affairs at nypd and he
set up these
drug stings where you know they've got
they tell this guy to like go and
babysit the crime scene where there's
you know a ton of cocaine on the table
and 20 000 in cash but nobody's been
there so they see what he does does he
pocket six grand and then report that he
seized fourteen thousand dollars what's
amazing about that story though is that
they have 500 of these they do they do
500 sting operations then they survey
the cops and they say how many of you
were subject to a sting in the last year
and 12 000 cops say they were subject to
a sting and the reason for that is
because if you put out 500 some of those
people are actually going to encounter
real situations where there's drugs on
the table and money on the table and
they're going to think it's a sting and
it starts to create this sort of
impression of like maybe this is just a
setup and there's some sort of healthy
dose of of
sense of you know potential consequences
the the really funny thing about that
study though is they they had um they
had like people which it's an amazing
job you can imagine the nypd they had
people like go up to cops and try to
like provoke them to punching them so
they would like they would like insult
them the force of the cops the insulting
pedestrians sting
it's it's right and like and if they if
they punch the pedestrian uh they would
you know face consequences or get fired
or whatever and and it's just like but
the value of this is that because it was
random the effect of it was much much
higher than if they'd actually said you
know oh we're going to do 50 sting
operations this year because then the
uncertainty doesn't exist now i don't
want to live in a dystopian society
where like the the break room fridge is
like baited you know to see who's gonna
take the the sandwich but i think for
people who are in immense positions of
positions of immense authority or
positions that are prone to abuse that
the occasional threat of random
oversight is very very effective i've
got it
members of congress just get offered
money at random
and then
in some cases it's like busted
and so then when members of congress get
offered stuff they'd be like oh i can't
take this
huh
am i fixing things
well you know i don't actually think
that's like the stupidest idea i think
that there's something i think there's
something to the so in the uk right now
there's this sleaze scandal they call it
where lo and behold the people who got
the contracts for a lot of the covid
services of testing and so on happened
to be people that were friends with some
of the ministers you know i don't
actually think it would be that bad of a
thing to occasionally plant you know
fake contractors i'm into it we should i
i wasn't really kidding we should
totally just have like freaking fake
fake real estate deals and other garbage
in there you know big stock market tips
fake pandemics
be like hey
you know and then see if they buy zoom
stock and then you're like busted
um this pandemic wasn't real
the last three were
so
no i'm i mean these systems
would be very very helpful i mean a lot
of them spoke to me as very consistent
with human behavior uh and a lot of them
you can actually try and marry a
political reform too
um i'm going to close with your last
principle
which i thought was very very powerful
and correct which is stop waiting for
principled saviors make them instead and
this is really the point of your book is
that look you have people you have
incentives and systems
and if you're waiting for superman to
come along then you know it's probably
not going to happen and oh by the way
superman probably couldn't fix this [ __ ]
anyway um so you need to do is you need
to try and actually make the system
attractive
and uh
the kind of
system that will attract and empower the
right people yeah i mean i think this is
the this is the ultimate answer to these
problems that we've all identified i
mean we're unhappy with our leadership
class we're unhappy with the people who
are seeking and obtaining power
so why don't we do anything about it you
know i mean we can we can just do hearts
and hope and
yeah exactly
so
we could we could wait and hope that
there's going to be some massive
you know wave of good leaders that just
sort of stumble upon our lives and and
fix everything that would be great if
that happened but i think we need to
think very very carefully about how you
engineer systems to ensure that those
people end up in power
and you know what i've been baffled by
is like why don't we have that
conversation like we always have
it's a brother doesn't give a [ __ ] about
what you're talking about our media just
wants to piss us off about the the the
person's wrong action or wrong statement
of the day and then we can decide who to
get mad at tomorrow who to get mad at
the next day um you know our media just
whipsaws people and their sentiments um
and a corrupt system doesn't make good
cable news
well
that's what i call like the tip of the
iceberg problem which is like you've got
this whole phenomenon around power the
systems the people who don't obtain it
under the surface the tip of the iceberg
is the people who are in power and it
makes sense to focus on them they're
visible they're they matter you might
crash into them but i think that that's
all we focus on you know we don't think
about the the system the people who
aren't making it into power the
introverts the the the different you
know candidates who couldn't possibly
win office because they don't have 12
million dollars in the bank you know
this
and and i think this is where
smart reforms can make a better world i
think that's the the really important
take and it's where i you know see eye
to eye with with a lot of what you're
doing is this is something where we can
change it we we're not like beholden to
a world where we just think our leaders
are corrupt and bad and self-interested
and narcissistic
you get this you get the people that you
have a system made for you know a rotten
system attracts rotten people a good
system attracts good people and our
system is rotten so
the answer isn't to just sort of berate
the people who end up there
makes sense we're going to do that
anyway it's to actually make the system
good so that we don't have to do that in
the end and i think that's the ultimate
uh answer to this this big problem of
how power corrupts people and how
corruptable people get power i agree
with you 100 we need to focus on the
mechanics of the system the incentives
it produces
it's why i'm doing the work that i'm
doing which is trying to diminish the
power of the extremes empower the
reasonable
somewhat silent majority
uh yeah so it's one reason why i enjoyed
your book so much i am going to suggest
something to you that you know it's
something that troubles me and this will
be our closing note
like right now the the system is run it
attracts rotten people it makes
reasonable people
less reasonable over time and more
rotten um and now there's this real
dubiousness where if someone comes along
um we just want to tear them down and i
will say that right now the media is
very much
animated by this energy it's like what
someone's trying to do something like
let's try and shiv that person in some
way
uh and because
you know they have to be corrupt and so
we we're going to show how corrupt they
are and this by the way is one of the
things that's dissuading a number of in
my view pretty good people from doing
something like running for office is
because they know
that to the extent they have any
foibles or dirty laundry it's going to
get dragged out for all to see you do
have an environment where you know that
there was a woman alexi hammond who
tweeted something that people didn't
like when she was a minor i think she
was like 17 and then she like loses her
job over that
um and so like in that environment uh
it's one of the concerns i have frankly
is like so you have this rotten system
you have this churn and then if someone
comes in now there's this impulse it's
like oh like let's let's tear this
person now what's wrong with them what's
wrong with them uh and so you have this
increasingly encoat mess
where
uh that your trust just gets uh lower
and lower
um so i i suppose i'm doubling down in
your case where this chain this sort of
change is very very much overdue because
it's contributing to the loss of trust
you know this is something that i
grapple that'll grapple with a lot when
i was writing the book because as i said
before i sat down with some really
unpalatable unpalatable people
but people are really complicated you
know i i wish that we could have that
conversation where it's just like
there's no
uniformly virtuous person and no
uniformly evil person for the most part
in our society a lot of shades of grey
yeah and and i think this is something
where you can have that grown-up
conversation you can say look we're not
looking for a saint we're looking for
someone who's going to make the world
better and that's something that i think
is is a really important recognition
because
otherwise you have a sort of random
effect too right like
randomly somebody who has a a terrible
view when they're 16 years old happens
to tweet it somebody who's 16 years old
doesn't tweet it says it to their friend
and one of them gets destroyed in one
dozen i mean that's that's that's
randomness right and it's it's something
where i think we don't want to engineer
systems where we insist upon 100 mistake
free leadership i think that also people
who make mistakes learn from those
mistakes so
to me you know i i grapple with this and
how i wrote about people who i don't
admire because some of the people in the
book that i sat down with i think did
some really vile stuff but i was trying
to convey
that they're they're dealing with
different pressures they're talking to
different systems they're navigating you
know a culture of power that's different
from ours
and
maybe we would behave similarly if we
were thrust into that position but
instead what we like to do is say oh
they're bad we're good you know and i i
think there's something
much more complicated going on where it
would be better for us as a society if
we didn't want to have somebody who was
100 perfect but instead was working hard
to make a system
better for the rest of us because that's
ultimately what the goal of politics and
power should be i love it i'm going to
suggest a litmus test for that person
brian
just term limits
74 of americans are four term limits if
you just said hey who's four term limits
just most americans instinctively sensed
a good thing
uh it would
really help a lot of the problems you're
describing i i'm going to suggest that
could be one litmus test uh and that
that's something i've been for since the
presidential is like look let's have
term limits um and i would certainly
feel the same way if i were in office
because i would be thinking let me get
done what i can get done and then get
the heck out of the way and let the next
person go
[Laughter]
so i'm just going to suggest that as a
potential
starting point that could activate a lot
of people and give you a sense as to
what's motivating a particular leader
yeah and i think these these reforms
have to happen in tandem because if you
ever if you have term limits but you
don't have campaign finance reform you
will have some people who end up you
know sort of taking the money and run so
to speak they figure they're they're
about to be out of office so they'll
just do whatever the lobbyists say which
is why i think you have to have lots of
reforms at once i think yeah you need
the sting operations you need the
campaign finance reform you need them
all
yeah and i don't i know exactly who to
put in charge of everything
brian class
anti-corruption czar
and then what we do is we give you a
helmet with like uh you know some some
weird insignia on it and then say if any
of you are corrupt
brian the incorruptable
will come and
chastise you and call you out what do
you think yeah i i think that's a
terrible idea i think that uh i would
not i don't think i would make a
particularly good president but it's
class the incorruptible
uh
that's going to be the the sequel to
your book which i did enjoy a great deal
i think it was very very interesting and
profound and correct corruptable who
gets power and how it changes us brian
class congratulations on this man it's a
it's a great book
uh really
fascinating profound and i hope a lot of
people read it and want to apply its
lessons
thank you so much andrew it's a pleasure
to talk to you
[Music]
you